for nearly two decades Israel's blockade
of Gaza has had a significant impact on
the people here
it's made even the most basic of life
activities especially religious ones a
significant challenge
as the celebration of riddle athaniers
The Soaring prices are making
sacrificial animals too expensive for
many in Gaza poverty rates are at 70
percent at a time when the average daily
per capita income does not exceed one
dollar
an unemployed father for the children
represents many other families in Gaza
we don't have money how can we work how
can we live the economy is burning
the impact on Farmers is equally grim
a local farmer tells us how difficult
it's been to adapt to the situation
while the number of customers goes down
along with Israeli blockade taxes and
soaring prices cattle feed is impacted
by 70 due to Russia's war on Ukraine
despite the gloomy situation there is
still hope the government in Gaza has
allowed its employees to pay for
sacrificial animal in installments
economic experts say factors beyond
gaza's borders affect what happens here
price increases are linked to
international events there's the price
of cattle feed and production costs as
well as the heavy local taxes despite
the years of blockade and economic
pressure people here in Gaza are
determined to celebrate the holy
festival and to take part in all
positions
[Music]